kaz's mission is to save one of the
world's great treasures southern
africa's wild savannah a bewildering
variety of animals have roamed these
wide open spaces for centuries but in
recent decades humans have encroached on
their territory as africa's population
grows thousands of farmers have settled
here to eke out a meager livelihood all
too often the result is what scientists
call human-wildlife conflict we think
you don't wanna leave you there were
seven elephants as soon as we heard that
we ran out to drive them away covino but
the elephants aren't afraid of us so
they just stay put they destroyed the
fields and suddenly our livelihood was
gone we fear for our lives to prevent
elephants from damaging farmland qasr is
developing protected corridors that keep
humans in animals apart they allow the
animals to roam across national borders
between the region's numerous game
reserves as they do so game rangers
monitor their progress and safety yeah
we are standing on a migratory route
that is coming from butanna to Angola to
Zambia and Angola unfortunately leaps
passes the trance as a busy highway
where it could be danger to wildlife
such as elephant and also people at the
same time cars as helping the locals
understand how they can actually benefit
from the very animals they sometimes
feel threatened by the idea is to
reconcile wildlife protection with the
economic aspirations of the rural
population Google is one where you're
protecting the elephants has created
jobs for the young people in our
community we also get a good income from
tourism from lodges and campsites then
we also have profi hunting in our area
hunting firms get licenses which also
bring us a lot of money went either
warmer out meanwhile cars is also
promoting itself as a top quality
tourist destination with the region's
animals and landscapes providing a
natural spectacle for visitors from
across the world
you